the russian troops keep on pouring in
there are armenians belarusians tajiks
and kurdish too but it is mostly
russians
almaty airport is heavily guarded their
mandate to protect key infrastructure
it means we still can't fly in to where
the most violent of last week's protests
happened where the shoot to kill order
is definitely still active
but international flights are now open
to the kazakh capital an 18-hour car
ride further north
sultan didn't see any of al marti's
upheaval a protest early on and
checkpoints now outside the city but
life goes on as normal even if the whole
country is now under a state of
emergency this city has undergone a few
name changes in its latest incarnation
as north sultan is in honor of no sultan
nazarbayev who is still technically what
the kazakhstan
leader of the nation but the question is
for how much longer
nazarbayev was the longest of central
asia's post-soviet strongman till he
handed power to his hand-picked
successor kasim jomat takayev in 2019.
rumors now arrive as to power struggles
among the elites that takayev was forced
to call on russia's help to fend off a
power grab
[Applause]
questions circulate who were these men
who turned the protests so violent why
were security services strangely absent
when shops and the airport were
ransacked
was the people's protest hijacked by
other forces and why hasn't nazarbayev
shown himself
one of the very few opposition voices in
kazakhstani politics
so do you think that the nazarbayev era
is over
he was accurate yes i think so
his time is over
he was supposed to have finished much
earlier but unfortunately it was a long
process and i think most of the problems
in kazakhstan are because of this
takayev now has a chance to prove
himself outside nazarbayev's shadow to
see if he responds to his people's
frustrations
or if he defaults to switching one
autocracy for another
dynamagnay sky news north sultan
kazakhstan